el diálogo se reanuda desde Caracas el
gobierno colombiano y la guerrilla de Ln
anunciaron que restablecerán las
conversaciones de Paz El próximo mes
pensamos que en esta oportunidad
las nuevas circunstancias políticas de
Colombia han permitido reiniciar las
negociaciones
entonces la confianza que tenemos ahora
es que hay un viraje en la política de
paz que históricamente ha tenido
Colombia la delegación del gobierno
colombiano aseguró que hay evidencias de
que el Ln ha reducido sus actividades en
muchos territorios y se mostró optimista
con la intención de acabar con los
enfrentamientos armados por parte de la
guerrilla las condiciones están ahí Ese
es el marco de nuestro diálogo la
transparencia
cualquier cosa que se acuerde es entre
las partes
y lo que se va acordando se va
cumpliendo el diálogo en sí mismo debe
expresar los cambios y esta delegación
de paz nos ha expresado y nos ha dado
elementos de profunda confianza la
primera mesa de negociaciones cayó en
2019 cuando el expresidente derechista
Iván Duque ordenó su disolución después
de un atentado perpetrado por el Ln en
una escuela de policía en la capital
Bogotá más de tres años después la gran
incógnita es si verdaderamente es viable
que a pesar del tiempo transcurrido y
los cambios dentro de la guerrilla y en
el propio país se podrán aprovechar los
pasos avanzados en el pasado Bueno lo
primero importante es que ya hay una
metodología que se avanzó en el gobierno
de Santos ya hay unos puntos que se
limitaron en el gobierno de Santos y ya
hay un camino que se ha avanzado no
vamos a arrancar de Cero y eso va a
ahorrar mucho tiempo en la negociación
Cuba Noruega Venezuela serán los
garantes y sedes del nuevo proceso
[Aplausos]